mit zugesendet von und zwar meint er
wieso also alle meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen sondern folge meiner
mama mama sitzt heute was ist denn heute
für tag heute ist freitag ja wochen eine
mir wurden wieder viele fakes zugesendet
mit fünf rausgesucht und die werde ich
euch jetzt vorstellen wenn ihr denkt ich
habe auch cool effect sich noch nicht
irgendwo gesehen sondern finde einfach
ganz cool dann sind mir doch bitte per
mail an ich lese wie er mail an
konkreter lg mail.com und dann würde ich
sagen ich würde mich freuen wenn du bist
meine dran bleiben würde und wir fangen
an mit fact nur der erste tag wurde mir
zugesendet von juni und 2 schreibt er
juni wende unter spielenden wm gesetzt
uns daran zudem bleibt es hängen anstatt
runterzufallen wir kennen das ja schon
von unter anderem satt und kitas und
spinnweben hängen dass der sand und der
kies dann einfach dadurch schlicht ich
mache das ganze jetzt einfach mal mit
tnt und zündet das an weil das tnt hüpft
ein ganz klein bisschen hoch wenn man
das ansinnen das ist tnt in dem action
pack das ist halt ein schwarzes geschenk
nachwuchs im monegassischen fürstenhaus
ok danke n-tv jedenfalls würde ich sagen
wir zum das ganze jetzt mal an und ihr
seht schon das ding hüpft hoch und
bleibt danach darin hängen also hier
zack zack bleibt aber dran hängen
rutschten ganze ein bisschen runter und
exklusion ist natürlich die gleiche also
die spinnweben stoppen nicht die
explosion
aber wir können das geld gucken wenn wir
dabei spielten neben ethischen meter in
3 1 sätzen gliedert der sand ganz okay
ich habe direkt auf gesetzlich vollidiot
ich muss selbstverständlich den sand
ihren setzen jetzt fällt er hier rein
und ihr glitter ganz langsam nach unten
bis er da ist wenn jetzt mal einen tee
runtersetzen das anzünden ist das
genauso und es geht mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit erste schon und es wird
ja alles in die luft gesprengt
der wand ist direkt und nun die zweite
sache wohl mit zugesendet vom und zwar
in
wieso also von commvault mir das
zugesendet und zweimal der traum wenn du
mit einem schwert recht auf einem blog
macht schlägt das schwert
wieso sollte das schlagen aber ich mag
einfach diese animation und es ist halt
schon ein wenig komisch und ich verstehe
das ganze auch nicht so richtig und zwar
wenn ich jetzt mal in die luft rechts
ich mache also wenn keine blöcke meiner
reichweite ist oder da hinten hinter ist
auch nicht mehr reiche leute reicht
vielleicht seht ihr schon hier mit f5
tag das ist ein ganz normaler block und
wenn ich hier draufklicken seht ihr auch
mit der 5 ist ein ganz normaler blog den
ich halt so mal zu abblocken also ihr
wisst was ich meine
allerdings nicht hin mache ist ganz
normal und hier schlägt der soll mal
ganz gut dass das schwert ganz normal
wenn ich so lange geht das ganze mal so
und wenn ich allerdings jetzt hier auf
dem blog geht das zack zack das geht so
einmal nach unten wahrscheinlich mal
wieder differenz schockiert sagt hier
zack zack zack das kommt von unten ich
habe keine ahnung was liegt da schlägt
irgendwie einmal so ganz kurz dann
irgendwie also zack einmal so von unten
und hier einmal so aber wenn ich mit der
fünf gucke ist beides das gleiche wird
allerdings nicht vom mc möller und ich
habe den verlag nicht mehr gehört
eigentlich sollte hier noch mal wieder
hören und ja wir kommen zu effekten
numero drei gute mit zugesendet von
bananen lp und zwar als etwas mit schnee
zu tun und zwar kennt hier ist ja ganz
normal wenn ihr schnee hat könnt ihr da
einen zaun draufsetzen geht der schnee
einfach da quasi direkter weg wenn ich
allerdings das ist ein ganz normaler
schnell ich sag mal so ein schnee
zwei stehen wenn ich jetzt ein zaun
aufsätze ist es schon so also es ist
quasi direkt darüber woran liegt das
trägt ihr euch vielleicht ist es auch
schon einigen klar und zwar ganz normal
ihr kennt das wenn ich hier durch schnee
durchlaufe der hier irgendwie liegt ich
erhöhe mich nicht von der position das
habe ich ja schon mal vorgestellt
das tue ich nämlich erst ab einer stufe
wenn ich nämlich so habe gehe ich jetzt
ein bisschen hoch ich denke das sieht
man wenn ich ihr so drauf hier zackig
ein bisschen hoch und zwar brauche ich
dann aber immer noch im schnee und zwar
bin ich so ein wenig im schnee drinnen
und gerade das sieht daran mit dem zaun
und zwar wenn ich jetzt hier einen drauf
setzte ist er quasi ihr seht schon ich
hoffe dann quasi auf einer stufe und der
ligue 1 einen block besteht aus acht
stufen schnee mehr oder weniger das
heißt kann jetzt noch sachen hinlegen
und dann sind wir hier fertig mit dem
blog und dann kann ich ja auch jeden
stein einen holzzaun draufsetzen
schwieriges wort
ich hoffe ich kann euch das irgendwie
versuchen zu erklären weil ich total
scheiße erklären also hier seht ihr
schon wenn ich da in schneereichen hier
seht ihr ich habe gar keine erhöhung
deswegen nimmt der schnee nimmt dir zaun
das nicht so als wirklichen blog da und
geht macht den quasi einfach weg wenn
ich allerdings zwei schnell war dann ab
seht ihr schon voller höhe gehe ich ein
stück höher das heißt es ist ein blog
der ein wenig höher geht ein achtel vom
blog geht dann höher und ist der zaun
nicht kaputt machen sondern geht dann da
oben drauf und das wollte mir beinahe
mit dem effekt sagen das war perfekt
dritte sache wurde mir zu gesellen von
sieben morden und zwar schreibt er wenn
man als abbaut und ein blogger ist kommt
wasser aus wenn aber kein blog darunter
ist kommt auch kein wasser raus ist
können wir ganz gut essen fragt euch
nicht warum ich nur so wenig herzens ab
ich habe vorhin schon paar sachen
getestet wie ihr seht schon hier
darunter befindet sich kein also hier
wunder befindet sich ein blog das heißt
ich letztmals einen einzigen bau dieses
eis ab und ihr seht schon da fließt
wasser ausgeht dann dementsprechend hier
in das loch
die ganze höhe überflutete wenn ich
allerdings jetzt beispielsweise mal ihr
seht schon das über ich kann der theorie
noch mal zum beispiel ich machte
theoretisch mal direkt daneben damit die
den unterschied seht hier ein blog
direkt darauf zeigt mit abgebaut das mit
dem abbauen dass das alles nie angezeigt
wird liegt an dem text ein bisschen
kleiner bagdad ich allerdings zwei
übereinander setzte bzw hier drunter ist
jetzt ja keinen block seht ihr schon
auch jetzt war das wasser thront an luca
um freunde wenn man das anders finden
uns mal ein erde block setzen den hier
hinsetzen da das eis drauf und jetzt
seht ihr
der ist jetzt tatsächlich nichts drunter
und wenn ich es jetzt abbauen die da
kommen doch kein wasser raus wenn ich
allerdings direkt auf dem boden habt
dann so und was wir gerade erfahren
haben meine lieben freunde wenn ich hier
einen eisblock hat und hier einen
eisblock und ich baue den ab da wird
dieses wasser hier trotzdem als block
anerkannt und ihr seht schon ein witz so
auch anerkannt ich denke ihr wisst was
ich meine wenn ihr es habt und ihr wollt
ich abbauen
kein wasser raus kommt oder so oder dass
da kein wasserdefizit ich habe gezeigt
also jemanden ganz kaputt und 40 euro
cinque ich weiß gar nicht warum ich
heute italienisch trip in wurde mit
zugelegt und zwar habe ich hier schon
feuerzeug und holt die kann ich hier
irgendwie inventar verteilt wie ich das
möchte und ich habe es beispielsweise
feuerzeug auf der einzelnes holzscheit
auf der 4
und wenn ich jetzt es holzschnitt mit
dem feuerzeug trug jetzt hier drauf und
pakete einzelnen und dann gehe ich auf
das holzschwert dann wisst ihr schon
weil ich das in den letzten folgen schon
mal gezeigt hatte dass das holzschwert
dass man mit dem schwert an entweder
blöcke abbauen kann oder dass es wie ein
bogen fungiert aber das schwert in die
verwandelt wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal
rechts ich mache sich aber im inventar
ich habe zwei feuerzeuge auf einmal mit
denen kann nicht beides mal das anzünden
aber ich hab das schwert nicht mehr das
heißt wenn ihr einen theoretischen die
mannschaft und ihr werdet es tauschen
ich weiß nicht ob es im zweifel auch
irgendwie funktioniert macht das jetzt
mal einfach irgendwie so guck mal hier
ich habe das diamant schwert oder jedes
diamant schwer tausches mit als kann mit
dem der menschheit direkt hier klicken
und es verwandelt sich in ein feuerzeug
ich weiß nicht ob es im game zu null
geht eigentlich könnte es mal ganz kurz
testen ich denke eigentlich nicht dass
es im game zu null geht weil ich denke
das geht nicht im game 1 0 aber wir sind
natürlich wird in minecraft weil man so
wird auch einfach mal testen kann sowie
clique man hier auf die einst klicken
hier rechts wegen ihrer funktion ihre
jetzt geht der sich erschwert dann
verwandelt quasi zu einem flinten stil
und das wurde mit susanne von nick und
da kann ich nicht und damit würde ich
sagen kommen wir ganz schnell zu einem
nicken nickname mit
ja das war es mal wieder für die micro
effekt meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr auch cool
effect anton tremmel dot com schreibt
mir eure meinung in die kommentare was
geht weiter woche